los fieles de su iglesia lo consideran
un apóstol pero un tribunal de los
ángeles lo sentenció a 16 años y 8 meses
de prisión por abuso sexual de tres
niñas nación joaquín garcía es el líder
de la mega iglesia evangélica a la luz
del mundo un culto basado en méjico pero
con más de 5 millones de seguidores en
el mundo entero garcía se declaró
culpable de tres cargos para evitar las
consecuencias de un juicio en el que
debía responder por seis crímenes contra
niños incluyendo violaciones
conspiración para cometer tráfico de
personas y pornografía infantil
quiero decirles a todas las víctimas
desconocidas que el mundo las ha
escuchado se los prometo
en cuanto a las familias que han
abandonado a sus desconocidas debería
darles vergüenza
simon
[Música]
y en cuanto al acusado digo que usted es
un depredador sexual
varios de sus devotos seguidores rezaron
por él en 2019 cuando fue detenido en
california por violación de una menor
porque algunos tenemos la oportunidad de
haberlo conocido desde su niñez con él
en la escuela secundaria
los antecedentes dicen otra cosa como lo
señaló una acusación del gobierno
mexicano luego de su arresto el segundo
caso tiene que ver con el bloqueo de
seis personas relacionadas con un grupo
religioso en donde había donativos que
se desarrollaban a la iglesia y una
práctica de pornografía infantil y de
explotación de naturaleza sexual la
condena sin embargo no deja satisfechas
a las víctimas que habían pedido la pena
máxima para garcía
seis años su error es un error
y tengo miedo por las vidas de las niñas
tengo bien miedo por nosotros
ayúdanos por favor la iglesia a la luz
del mundo emitió un comunicado
reiterando su apoyo a garcía y
asegurando que no había tenido un
proceso justo